好我们上个礼拜说
好像每一天都有点鬼故事
今天虽然盘面上看起来是不错的
没有受到廉价或战争的影响
可是探针系列
尹卫却杀了一个谍停板
到底发生什么事情呢
这边来请教余晨了
刚刚提到
三个来宾都提到
发哥破5000
所以看来是盘面上亮点中的亮点
但你要帮我们延伸了
因为它代表的就是
自研晶片ethic
绝对是第四季到明年的大戏
再来
今天的封測股表現很奇妙
百元以下很多漲停
但是探針系列卻是一個重錯
你會選誰 多吉
我會選靠近聯發科的
靠近聯發科的
跟聯發科越有關係越好
是 那不就雍智嗎
是可以考慮
那我們要討論這件事情之前
我們要注意到一個新聞
因為去年的這個時候
去年這個時候
GIMANI3橫空出世
展現了很好的簡報的邏輯能力
簡報 繪圖都比過去強很多
然後文字的辨識也變得非常強
大家記得嗎
就一開始當要用AI用GPT的時候
文字的辨識會有一些很奇怪的文字有沒有
有到GIMANI 3的時候
這個能力大幅度進化
好用很多
對 那最近這一整年
坦白講GIMANI的這個進化
是
不如預期
那我們看到像GPT
前一陣子剛推出的這個GPT 6 Extra
然後這個Fable 5.1
這個是那個Astrapic推出的
這兩個性能都非常強
在這一年當中都超車了GIMANI 3的風芒
可是GIMANI 4
慢慢的
有一點悄悄的
衝出江湖
好 所以今年的話
我們準備迎接GIMANI 4 Pro
對 那這個GIMANI 4
它現在還沒有開始正式發表
可是在論壇上面
已經可以看到它一些跑分的成績
怎麼樣
它跑分成績
它對手跟這個GPD-6
跟這個Cloud Fable 5.1來比的話
至少都不相上下
那你可以看一下
譬如說像它的成本
成本的部分
GIMANINE是低很多
這很重要
對 那再來就是說
譬如說像這個
編寫程式的能力啊
或者是說像這種金融分析
法律任務等等
這個都比這個
都比Google
都比這個GPT6
然後還要比Fable 5.1
都還要表現來的強硬
所以呢 這個GP
所以GIMANINE
它到底好不好用
它其實表現真的不錯啦
那重點是它背後的工程是誰
背後的工程就是這個
這個是它自己的晶片
好 TPU
Google自研晶片
這個TPU帶來怎麼樣的經濟效益
那Google Cloud
Google Cloud就說
這裡面圖上面有兩條線
一條是實線 一條是虛線
那這個實線代表說
如果是Google Cloud
他用GPU的方法來去做運算的話
他成本大概要兩年才會回本
大概要兩年多
兩年多會回本
GPU太貴了
GPU稍微比較貴一些
可是他自己用他自己的TPU
他回本時間很神奇
變成一年多
那Google告訴我們說
它的客戶跟它簽的合約
大概都是五年以上
所以你想想看
原本兩年回本的合約
它現在一年就回本了
那表示說這個TPU的算力表現
可以幫它帶來更大的經濟價值
就是回應到趙華最前面講的
Asic的大時代
其實你可以看
這個Google TPU
它的這個每個世代在推出
誰最受惠
你這太難了吧
對也是來回禮台大安秀出考題的
那這張錶上有密密麻麻好多
密密麻麻看起來有點複雜
那其實重點只有兩個
簡單講
重點只有兩個
哪兩個
第一個重點呢
當然是我們發哥占據很多嘛
占據很多塊嘛
先問MTK這三個字
MTK就是我們聯發哥
那上面橫軸這個是代表是
每個晶片世代
TPU的晶片世代在推進
怎麼樣
那當然是MTK越多
表示他拿下晶片越多嘛這是其中一可是這個還不是最大的重點不然呢重點這一欄喔這一欄全部被你化掉了全部都被槓掉了那這一欄這一欄表示什麼意思
它是說
它是說TPU在第九代的時候呢
它原本呢
有一顆兩顆三顆的這個晶片
可是呢
這一顆晶片通通都取消了
通通取消了
為什麼
可能考量成本啦
考量性能等等的一些想法
那誰被取消了
Broadcom
博通的 博通的晶片被取消了
所以呢
原本呢從這個 TPU 的 V9 可能就是
博通有好幾顆
然後聯發科也有好幾顆
可是現在呢
博通被取消一顆
那對於聯發科來說
它是什麼意思
它是 Share Again
是
它就試占率就變大了
好 本來 1 2 3 4 對不對
然後發哥 1 2 3 4
對
但是現在發哥還是 4
博通變成 3
對 所以對於這個 TPU 的試占率來說
聯發科就是最大的贏家
好那接下來重點就是說
既然聯發科來了
聯發科會隨著這個TPU的貢獻
未來也會越來越棒
那重點是
那接下來我們投資的方向
當然就是要去朝著聯發科
來去做貼近
對啊 就除了他
我們還是希望知道有沒有別人
例如說最近創意也很厲害
可是世新KY就有點躺在地上
我們當然希望能夠找到
可以補漲或是還有潛力的
是 那我們講到說
這個整個ASIA概念果
你看這上面的這個表現
今天表現都大概大部分都還不錯
不過世新KY也因為有說
有幫人家投片的關係
所以毛利率會受到一點影響
怎麼看這個事情
沒有錯 可是它的營收會變得非常
營收會變大
營收會變超級超級的大
對 那那個
毛利率的部分
因為你做TUNKEY
它毛利率多多少少會下降
其實聯發科的這個毛利率
它也會慢慢下降
可是它有一個好處
就是說它的費用率
它費用 研發費用
會慢慢也會慢慢降下來
所以它整體來講
以這些IP 廠來看的話
它的獲利其實還是會往上來去做推升
所以你看跟聯發科
廠商跟聯發科關係特別好的
譬如說像
我今天有幫大家列第三季營收的達成率
這營收達成率就是說
現在我們把7加8月的營收加起來
去跟法人預期比一比
達成大概多少
你可以發現跟聯發科關係較好的
大概都有6成6以上
這表示如果說9月份的營收
輕輕鬆鬆卡拉拉
不要越減太多
就算是小越減
他還是有機會
去讓法人
要持續的來去做上修
好 上修
而且可能對於明年
搞不好還有上修的機會
對 沒有錯
那我們就來看一下
這幾天公司的財務表現
因為聯發科的這個
剛剛兩萬專家
已經講很多技術面了
我就不講了
所以你要講一些不一樣的
對 重點是在於說
評價面的部分
聯發科評價面
因為聯發科畢竟
已經來到五千塊
但到底還有沒有空間
聯發科到明年了
大概是這個YYY會翻倍
EPSYY是有機會來去做翻倍
然後28年的部分
還有機會來去做翻倍
不是DUM有把它喊到EPS400嗎
對 那可能要再往後面一點
我們不用看那麼的遠
但是以現在它這個價位
我覺得大概Price in
這個27年的成長
大概沒有什麼太大問題
那你看它現在的營收
這是兩條它每年的營收曲線
紅色線是去年
灰色線是今年
那今年跟去年比
其實沒有什麼太大成長
但是你想想看
聯發科就算
就算不怎麼下半年
下第四季不怎麼表現
這個歪歪還是非常大
好 它8月已經算是
讓市場覺得很亮眼
對 本來以為不太成長
重點是8月TPU還沒進來
它就已經一直升高
對 那其他跟聯發科
關係很好的這些測試場
像是月光 金融電
新權 系格
那這些他們的營收表現都非常的好那這個圖要怎麼看呢重點就是在於說綠色的線就是今年的表現那過去其他線就是前面幾年的表現那你可以看綠色的線跟前面幾年的表現
差距越遠 飛起來了
對 就表示說它的這個
表示它YOY越大
成長力越驚人
那這裡面有一個貓尼
就是大家會覺得說
好像說日月光很強
但是金元電稍微偏弱一些
比較緩
對 這在財務上面有一個重點
就是在於說折舊費用
哦 金元電今年折舊應該比較多
對 因為今年金元電前上半季
就是上半年第一季跟第二季
他折就歪歪歪大概都五成多
因為他的資本支出已經灑下去了
所以他折就費用非常重
那第三季我們就看一下
這個折就費用能不能夠降下來
那如果說有降下來的話
其實金元電還是有機會
可以來去做補漲的
好 金元電的股東們謝謝你
因為產物朋友很關注
金元電怎麼漲這麼慢
對 那其他的這個封設廠
他當然就還是持續受到
外衣效果的這個受惠
那我們從K線圖來看的話
聯發科他因為剛過這個歷史新高
管線上面會有一些震盪整理
那這也不用過度擔心
你拉長線來看的話
還有剛剛講到
它未來的二八年成長
還是有機會
那大家比較有疑慮是像這個世新KY
世新KY 怎麼了
好 世新KY 的重點就在於說
它的客戶的結構
跟其他兩間的IP 廠比較不一樣
因為像聯發科跟創意
它的客戶結構比較分散
產品也比較多元
那世新KY 的客戶
大概就是靠
亞馬遜 Training 3 這個系列
所以它會很容易受到
亞馬遜的這個
拉貨的動 拉貨的變
節奏來去做變化
所以今年的這個營收啦
雖然說七八月有一個大飆升
可是它還是有比較明顯的delay
所以接下來的重點就是在於說
你要期待四星KY的營收
不要再出來了
什麼意思啦
不要再出來
因為你如果
怎麼可能每月
就是每個月都要出來啊
對 因為你如果數字
還是持續很好看的話
四星KY會把它今年機期
拉得非常的高
那對於27年來看
2025年的話
對四星KY就會相對比較不利
但是如果說假設說
假設說接下來第四季
它的月營收就持平放緩了
然後把這個確年3
遞延到明年去
它就會發生
明年的YY要提升
雖然說今年YY下降
可是明年的YY提升
那在評價面看起來
會稍微比現在還要再有利一些
你太狠了吧
他對不對
他8月營收年增200多%
市場都不買單了
你還要他不要再提升了
因為你今年就這樣子了
因為你今年就
你去當財務主管好了
就是如果說
因為缺年3跟缺年4
缺年3拉貨還是蠻確定的
但是確實有些delay
那當然說這個delay狀況
會影響到今年的評價面的表現
但是如果說這個拉貨的時程
你往後放長一點的話
把這個獲利貢獻到明年去
那對於四星開發
有可能在這個
在第一檔打個底之後
搞不好還有機會再重新上去
就等於大家做明年的夢的時候
比較好講了
對 好那講到說
低價封測
因為剛剛講外溢效應
會不斷的外溢出來
像今天的南茂跟華東
表現得也是不錯
我覺得他們主要還是有一些
集團作帳的影子
比如說像8110的華東
跟華新集團作帳
還是比較有關係
但是這兩間公司
確實在今年的獲利
也表現不錯
但是裡面結構有些差別
就像華東
他的今年上半年的
第二季的獲利
業外貢獻比較多一點點
業外貢獻比較多
對 那南茂部分呢
靠本業比較多
所以南茂部分
雖然兩間公司跟記憶體封測
都比較有關
但南茂的獲利表現
我個人認為是再更好一些
所以我認為如果說新權系格
位階也比較高
你買不下去
可以多看一下南茂部分
好 但是新權系格
還是你心目中的首選喔
對
好 那再來一個
就是講到結尾問的這個探針卡
怎麼了 好
大家看到跌停都怎麼了
其實今天盤中
我們也在研究說是不是有什麼小作文但其實沒有看到啊對 那我剛剛講到說27年其實是一個大封測的時代大封測大IP的時代那這個大封測時代
你不可能全部都靠測試廠
因為測試廠它做得很辛苦
它當然又耗材就要弄比較多一點
那探針卡一年一年
都要再不斷的來去做迭代
短線上面引位比較弱
主要還是受到籌碼面的影響
這籌碼面的調整
這邊外資跟投信有互相
土羊都在吐欸
互相有做一些調解
可是我覺得以這個Sake的部分
你拉長線來看的話
它還是一個沒有辦法去
無可或缺的一個探針的材料
那再來就是說這個旺系的部分
旺系的部分我覺得蠻有趣的
大家可以注意一下它的可轉載
它還有一檔可轉載就6.2.3.6
就旺系6
像旺系今天中錯5%
可是旺系6跌0.5%
所以裡面就是暗示著
對
後續要拉起來轉換的機率還是很高
因為它的轉換價就6200塊
你想想看這個上面的投資人
他堅守在
可轉債上面的目的是什麼
一定是覺得說這個股價
還有往上轉換的空間
所以我覺得大家可以注意一下
它可轉債跟它現貨的差距
好這是從網面的觀察
其實這兩檔外資的目標價
都在萬元
都沒有改變
對
好 那最後部分
上次跟大家講過這個PTFE的材料
幫我們追蹤一下
因為題材好像一旦有點淡掉
他們就開始往下跑
對 那我覺得這個時候
弱勢也不見得是一個壞事
因為最近CCL的這個題材
受到說大家很擔心說
未來高階的需求不太需要
會嗎
因為PTFE本來就是一個高階的材料
所以當然說你高階的M10 M9
你不用 當然也不用到PTFE了
可是這個短時間之內
至少在28 29年都還看不太到
所以我覺得這個PTFE
它還是會再持續的來去做認證
那這個認證
現在就看認證進度
那你會發現說
雖然說這個時候股價比較弱勢
可是未來三不五十
三不五十就會再討論說這個題材
這個材料它也有過認證
會有新的應用等等
那我覺得這個長線上面
回到長期均線
都是一個不錯的布局時機
好 等於CCR
其實大家可能忽略了
也綁到了PTFE
都是材料升級的概念
但是這兩年法人
或者公司自己都有出來講
升級的腳步應該是不可能因此放緩的
所以回到重要均線
如果法人的籌碼願意回來的話
可能會再展開一波的掌勢
這邊非常謝謝余辰
謝謝長寶
余辰每次來都帶來非常珍貴的表格
今天也讓大家耳目一新的是
原來現在要怎麼樣
靠攏在聯發科的旁邊
要靠攏在可以拿到晶圓的產能
拿到封測產能的人旁邊
這些都會是整個2027年
非常重要的一件事情
還有ESSIC自研晶片
可以讓各家的AI大廠加速回本的時間
好 在加速的過程中
我們的晶片廠商就佔有非常重要的地位
我們看到了這些晶片裡面
剛剛本來聯發坑跟博通勢均力敵
現在博通有一顆晶片拿掉了
所以我們的競爭力是毋庸置疑的
情勢正在往台灣的半導體廠吹過來
那剛剛也特別提到
幫我們加碼看了PTFE相關的
好 最近材料升級這件事情
在PCB有点杂音
但不要担心
接下来如果法人愿意回头
而均线有手的话
材料升级依旧是
2027年很重要的议题
就等这个题材回来吹
好 今天非常谢谢
三位来宾来到现场
这个礼拜只有四个交易日
可是盘面却有非常多的
大事情要关注
川习会还有很多
跟半导体相关的论坛
都会带动我们的股票往前走
那也希望今天的
理财杂安秀对您投资有帮助
明天再会了 拜拜
by bwd6